Gregg Alba John Humphrey we're gonna
talk today about this oceans eight film
an image has been released of them
sitting on a subway so exciting
I'm so glad they're promoting this film
with the best shot they could get of all
yeah sitting on a subway public
transportation wide it's not like an
Expendables front cover well they're all
it is smiling make you question the Tony
I'm excited for this I know I haven't
really chimed in on notions eight really
but oceans eight I'm actually genuinely
excited for this because this isn't like
a typical you know female reboot kind of
thing to me where you know like I get
why people were upset over Ghostbusters
I could still see kind of see why people
were a little distant I like the
Ghostbusters movie honestly already got
much dislikes just for saying that I saw
it again recently it's still fun yeah
oh she's ain't I don't feel has the same
kind of like cuz the oceans longer
already a remake no one's gonna be like
on my childhood yeah Ocean's eleven was
already a remake and the first one was
great second one within the third one
some people really loved the third one
and I was on the side that did not love
the third one I was on the side that did
not see this this is smart because I
think Sandra Bullock playing Danny
ocean's sister I could totally see them
being brother and sister even though
Danny ocean's probably not gonna make a
cameo in this one no a surprise ending
cameo what is George clean up to like an
ending cameo yeah if they were if we
were ready to get or like he helps out
with the like the final part of the
planet the last although that could
actually ruin the film because they're
taking away from the cast here yeah it
makes that mean except Danny ocean
solves it I think would be funny if he
just called her at some point unrelated
be funny he [ __ ] off the plan Danny we
got yeah I'm excited it because I know
the villains being played by Damian
Lewis star of homeland
knows a star mom at my favorite Stephen
King adaptation dreamcatcher
oh it's everyone's favorite that's
everyone sweet was a hands-down the best
one best one but this cast is really
cool you got Sandra Bullock in here Cate
Blanchett's
Sarah Paulson Anne Hathaway Helena
Bonham Carter Mindy Kaling Aquafina and
Rihanna and I think it's smart to
condense it down to eight because the
prong with the Ocean's eleven movie is
because you only think about like four
of those actors what do you think about
this George Clooney Matt Damon Brad Pitt
you started backing Andy Garcia you try
to name them all you lose it end up
counting that Damon twice yeah I think
this is a great chance because we're
probably gonna obviously get a lot more
spending time dedicated to Sandra
Bullock and it sounds like Cate
Blanchett as well because she's supposed
to be the right-hand woman yeah but you
know you got this other casters or
Paulson is an amazing actress and she
just went like a Golden Globe or an Emmy
or something Thanks yeah 400 J yeah
place for playing Oh jail isn't really a
hearse of roll kind of controversy on it
did I mention Rihanna's in this yeah
Harry on isn't it yeah battleship that
was acting a lot
yes she's Marion crane on Bates Motel
and she's also in the new movie that's
called Oh little area in the city of a
thousand planets yeah
and Hathaway Helena but these are all
great actors to be in here and I feel
like we can actually get a serviceable
amount of good screen time for the rest
of the supporting cast well most of all
primarily be dedicated as Sandra Bullock
and Cate Blanchett I'm wondering who
will be the standout actress though
Mindy do you think Mindy accounting will
be Mindy
it sounds like it could be really funny
too you got some pretty plant aquafina
I'm not familiar with her work I am not
to this super diverse cast got black
chicken Indian chick a Chinese chick
couple British yeah well and that's the
thing is like what I like about these
movies that I liked about the first one
is like you have enough main characters
that you can kind of get diverse to the
casting not only in terms of like you
know ethnic diversity but also you know
you get people from the comedy world you
get people from music and and I feel
like this is a place where that can be
appropriate yeah there are some times
when they shove you know like Rihanna
into something aren't acting or somebody
like Rihanna into something where I'm
like I don't think this needed to happen
but here I can definitely see that I
wonder what this style of the film will
be like though you know cuz Gary Ross
while he's not some cool films like
Pleasantville and Seabiscuit you know
Hunger Games the first one I really
liked the first Hunger Games but he
hasn't done something for me where I'm
like I could seem pretty good
cool heist fun film yeah it seems like
his movies kind of take their time at
least the ones that I've seen maybe not
so much the Hunger Games but even the
Hunger Games you spend a lot of time in
the nitty gritty of just like living in
district 12 the first Ocean's eleven
struck this good balance of good it
didn't feel like they're just hanging
out it still felt like those actors came
prepared they're gonna do their work
they're gonna give it their all but they
still had a fun time doing it where as
opposed to the second and third one
there kind of just chillin hey you know
Mike there showed up to collect their
checks okay I know he's gonna want to
bring good character this it's one thing
I really like about Gary Ross is I know
he cares about the characters um
wondering will he be able to really
strike a good comedic tone for this yeah
I'm curious about that too cuz the only
thing I'm really concerned about or that
I really feel strongly about in coming
back to the oceans property at all is
like what I remember liking the most
about the first couple of movies aside
for the ensemble is just that like I
don't know how to describe it even that
sort of swanky not this is in New York
this time but that swanky Vegas sort of
like there's always a rhythm there's
like that bass music you know it's got
that sort of high scale heist quality so
yeah like knowing Gary Ross's style I am
curious you know is this gonna be a
tonal shift or is this gonna have a
little bit of that Soderbergh you know
Lee has to make it his own because soda
brick has a very distinct Flair and
especially for the oceans movie had a
very distinct style for them I feel like
Gary Ross has to make it his own I'm
just wondering what exactly he's gonna
do and with this cast it sounds like
this will be more comedic yeah I look at
the cast you know you got to strip
comedians in this movie Sandra Bullock
there's a lot of comedies and she does a
lot of drama it's like Oh totally you've
got a half and a half for me anyway cuz
you've got you know Cate Blanchett
Sandra Bullock and Hathaway and Sarah
Paulsen who all to me are like character
actresses room you know or even if not
character actresses but still like at
least what I've seen them in recently
they're always throwing down on a
performance and so again that's the
diversity that I've been curious about
but I definitely think you've got at
least two straight-up comedians in here
you've got Rihanna there's definitely
you're missing Melissa McCarthy Kristen
Wiig oh yeah totally you can't do a
funny movie without those two no kate
mckinnon let's get her in here too
cam mackinnon and Leslie Jones to know
you that we smart dude ocean's 8 meets
ghostbusters sequel oh my gosh
why have they not announced this yet
heist in a haunted casino come on Maya
Rudolph and Rudolph as the villain and
Tim Meadows in like a small supporting
character no wow Andy Samberg yeah [ __ ]
the whole coolness let's make it a
straight-up comedy sketch goes ocean are
you guys excited for oceans 8 are you
are you are you is this year is this the
franchiser most dedicated to put your
comments below this means they can make
at least three before it gets
problematic sure subscribe to the real
rejects John is reason to Jerry on
Twitter and Instagram and he's a social
media manager of bloom house and the
real rejects right and shout out to
Jennifer Lopez Jennifer Lopez
boy-next-door
I am so glad you're not involved in this
film oh how come you don't like JLo not
really why not ass is too fat ouch
I like flattened butts I like flat butts
and I cannot lie yeah it's me like a
flat ass you're flat chested flat ass
woman out there you hit me up a message
on Instagram